to get another rush to judgment over a
deadly police shooting
this is a tragedy there's no denying
that but democrats in the media racing
to politicize an
officer killing 16 year old michaela
bryant
who had a knife in her hand and was
lunging at another girl
instead of waiting for all the facts the
white house said this
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people in communities
and that black women and girls like
black men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence
and now liberals in the media are trying
to downplay the dangers
of knife fights former obama white house
advisor valerie jarrett tweeting quote
a police officer immediately decided to
shoot her multiple times in order to
break up a
knife fight and a cnn guest said this
and the question we have to ask
ourselves what if it were your daughter
what if it were
your child what if it were a member of
your family your neighbor
uh in a uh essentially a teenage fight a
schoolyard fight
but maybe they should listen to the girl
wearing pink
who could have been stabbed
[Music]
she came out at you with a knife earlier
no she just
that's what the guy that's what the
police she came after me
with a knife yeah so he got her right
well first of all it's not a nice fight
when only one person has a knife that's
that's a butcher shop all right so juan
williams you're an officer
you get out of the vehicle you see
mayhem there's a guy that's kicking a
girl down to the ground
and another woman lunging at a
a defenseless woman like this with a
sharp blade
you have seconds to react she doesn't
put the knife down when you warn her
what does juan williams officer juan
williams do
to save the lady's life in pink
well i guess i would shoot the gun not
necessarily at somebody but maybe shoot
the gun
and maybe you know run at the person and
try to disarm them like i don't know i
mean
so wait wait wait you would shoot the
gun in the air like a warning shot
not well hopefully to distract or to try
to
stall or something so i could get or my
partner could get the
knife away i see is what i was saying
well i don't know i mean taking
someone's wife is pretty strong
i don't either i don't either jesse i
mean jesse policing is tough work
um but all i'm saying is you know i
think
i think that that woman with a knife is
a danger to society it's certainly a
danger to the other person and we want
her to
stop and be disarmed i just i just also
think
that killing a human is pretty radical i
don't think that's a good thing
but what i see overall here you know you
asked me what i see i see
people now using this ohio case which is
messy as you and i just discussed
to somehow really try to change the
subject you know from what happened in
minnesota with the
chauvin guilty verdict with the george
floyd murder on tape
which is right now prompting
a lot of eyes to open in america to the
idea
that really there is a problem with
policing that what black people have
been saying about police brutality and
abuse and lack of accountability
for police who engage in that kind of
behavior is a real
problem in america so i think a lot of
people just want to change that
conversation
by looking at this case whether it's not
clear
who's in the right and wrong all that we
know is you know with some certainty
that
deadly force had to be used a lot of
people are saying gosh
you know why do we have to do that every
time
i don't know greg if people are trying
to change the conversation this
conversation
was thrust upon us by really disgusting
headlines that made it look like this
was a racial execution
and and nbc actually got caught
deceptively editing the video to make it
look like the girl didn't have a knife
and they edited the 911 call
again we're back to cleaning up another
racially charged story
that has been foisted upon us in order
to divide us
the only time the media is interested in
looking at the complexities
of this stuff is when they are caught
out on it
right no one changed the subject no one
changed the subject the media embraced
this story
and they pushed it to the forefront
because they thought it was going a
certain way
and then suddenly when it went another
way people started deleting their tweets
right
but the real out and the fact is juan
says these stories are messy
we've been saying that every time we
have eight or ten of these a year
we go these are each one of these cases
is so different
but it's immediate that is trying to
make them sound exactly the same and
it's not
it is messy but here's the real outrage
we have lowered our expectations so much
that we
deem uh knife fight as an acceptable
part of
childhood if that is true right we need
to examine
these childhoods instead instead of
making disgusting excuses
we saw two narratives collide last night
police shooting a suspect which the
media
obsesses over black on black violence
which the media ignores
but you can't have the former without
the latter police
end up at the end of these people's
lives
because they were called there due to
the violence
that the media ignores cops end up in
situations
caused by the problems that are
dismissed
so they end up there because it's their
job to be there at the
end and no it's not juan or me that has
to rush in
and and not make this decision it's that
guy
he can't ignore it he has to show up and
risk
everything too if we imagine if we
honestly tackled the problems
at its roots the piss-poor education the
violence
mental wellness family structure what if
we examine the variables
that end up with the police there at the
end of a person's
life rather than dismiss it as a heart
dismissing it as a harmless knife fight
or
what jen stacky said those are the
variables that contribute to this
because the more you dismiss the
variables that lead to this horrible
tragedy
the more it keeps coming this is not
about a police officer this is about
everything everything that led to that
moment and if you deny that
you are you are propagating this problem
you are part of the problem
so digging greg makes an excellent point
which he does once in a while
and that is that if you reduce the
number of 9-1-1
calls coming from these communities
you're going to reduce the chances
of these horrific very messy
officer involved shootings isn't that
right
right and people will die if the police
are not there for them
i you can look at that video one of two
ways
that was a police officer saving the
life
of a young black woman and you know what
when the police aren't there
people die in another part of ohio
earlier this week
in cincinnati a 13 year old
was stabbed to death by another 13 year
old
the girl who died naira givens she was
stabbed
by another who's been charged with
murder
i'll leave it at that but what's
happened with this the
left-wing liberal framing of all of this
and this is their
modus operandi that you get ahead of the
actual
facts and that you do or ignore them
or lie to make sure that you shape the
story
to the to their narrative at all cost so
the narrative is cops are evil this
country is racist
down with america and then the preferred
outcome is that we destroy
the nation as exist right now to rebuild
it it's a
craven power grab ridiculous if it
wasn't so insidious
but i'll point to the verdict in the
derek chauvin trial
guilty on all counts justice
for george floyd's family certainly but
see that
pointed to the fact that the justice
system
is not systemically racist that a cop
who
oversteps his power and kills another
individual
will be brought to justice will be sent
to prison for the rest of his life
but see that didn't fit the left's
narrative so they're trying to
they tried to change the subject with
this uh shooting this police shooting
in ohio so what does the left do the
tensions are cooling
you got to bust out that canister of
kerosene
you got to keep the lie alive yell
louder
yeah martha one of the things that i
found pretty disturbing was watching
a lot of african-american pundits look
at this video and basically come to the
conclusion that
we should just let them stab each other
don't get involved
you know don't don't try to break it up
you know knife fights happen
let's just let them slash each other to
death it's
that was pretty shocking to hear you
know i mean as degen just brought up the
other case that she talked about i
looked up the number today of
young people under the age of 18 who
have been killed
in violent events like this in 2021
there's 441
children that you have you never hear
about and al sharpton does not show up
for their funeral
the white house never talks about them
and this police officer intervened
in a situation that might have ended
like that did you know this is a tragedy
obviously this young person lost their
life and the bottom line is
that we don't know what happened here
yet so this is why i don't think anybody
should walk to the podium at the white
house
and make judgments about what happened
i'd like to see the kind of
responsibility that we used to see when
when situations like this were dealt
with where you say look we see what's on
this video
and there's an investigation that's
underway and we
are keeping an eye on it and we're going
to find out we're going to see where it
leads we're going to allow them to do
this
i'm watching to see what happens to a
man named ned pettis
ned pettis is the columbia safety
officer
columbus ohio safety officer and he
urged everyone not to rush to judgment
and we all saw what happened to the city
manager in minneapolis who said the same
thing
who said hold on everybody let's just go
through the process let's see what
happened in this situation let's go
through it play-by-play
and he lost his job so i hope ned pettis
doesn't lose his job
for urging a little bit of circumspect a
little bit of caution a little bit of
maturity and responsibility when we look
at these situations
to not rush to judgment everybody that
you just showed who's already been
talking on tv
they all know what happened i guess well
they weren't there and they don't know
exactly what happened all they know is
what they see in that video and there's
a lot more to this story to be told
yep and we'll follow that as it develops
coming up next